الموضوع هو هدايا من قلب جون
، وفي هذا العام ، أرادت جيل بايدن أن
تعكس الوحدة ، فالأشياء التي تجمعنا
معًا ، كان الكثير من الأشجار يوجه الإيماءات إلى
أوائل المستجيبين العاملين في الخطوط الأمامية ،
ويشكرهم بشكل أساسي
الأشياء التي شعرت أن الوباء قد تسبب فيها
أخذ الأشياء التي يحتاج الناس إلى
تذكرها
سوف تشكر جيل بايدن
المتطوعين مائة أو نحو ذلك من المتطوعين
الذين جاؤوا لتزيين البيت الأبيض
خلال الأسبوع الماضي في
وقت لاحق من بعد ظهر هذا اليوم شخصيًا ، لكن في
الأساس شعرت وكأنها
زينة عطلة منزل أبيض أكثر هدوءًا  مما كان عليه الحال في
السنوات الماضية بالطبع ، نحن نخرج
من هذا الوباء الذي نأمله وأراد بايدن
أن يعكسوا
ذلك الشكر لأنهم
شعروا بالامتنان لعدم
وجود أشجار حمراء مثيرة للجدل ، فلنضع
الأمر على هذا النحو لا يوجد شيء في
الزينة التي ستسبب حقًا
قدرًا هائلاً من المحادثات ولكن
جيل بايدن كانت متورطة للغاية ، فقد
اختارت الموضوع الذي اختارته بعضًا من
أو  الأسماء التي قررت أنها تريد تعليق
الجوارب مع أسماء أحفادها
على الموقد في غرفة الطعام الحكومية ،
حتى أنها وضعت
الشخص الأخير أمام مكان إعداد خبز الزنجبيل
أمام مدرسة ، لقد كانت
معلمة بالطبع هي معلمة لذا
فهي شديدة  البيت الأبيض العملي
لا يزال مغلقًا أمام الزائرين في الوقت الحالي ،
لكننا نتوقع بعض
الإعلانات حول ذلك ربما
يفتح للزوار لرؤية زينة العطلة هذه